in this world's largest refugee camp
there are many who suffers in silence
unable to share their trauma because of
extreme shame
and stigma we met up with the 41 year
old rohingya men
who says he was tortured and sexually
assaulted by myanmar soldiers
he didn't want it to be identified
they took me into an open space in a
valley nearby and beat me up badly
then i was raped just like they would
rape a woman kept me there till 4 in the
morning
the very thought of this brutal
experience makes me go into severe
depression
i feel so traumatized i go through much
mental angus and pain most of the time
it's unbearable research by the us-based
women's refugee commission in myanmar
found systematic targeted premeditated
sexual violence committed against men
and boys you don't hear much about
sexual violence against rohingya men and
boys
rights group and ngo said there are
significant number of male
rape victims but they're very ashamed to
come forward
and talk about their ordeals and that
they're largely overlooked
and neglected by humanitarian agencies
another 45 year old man says he was
sexually assaulted by myanmar troops in
2006.
he suffers from chronic depression
they stripped me naked and first
penetrated me with a stick
then one of the border policemen raped
me later they sent me to a jail
even if there is justice my trauma will
never end only my death will relieve me
from this pain
just a few days ago a friend of mine
with a similar experience
died in a recent international
organization for migration study
14.2 percent of the male rohingya
respondents say
they're victims of sexual violence this
year we've
we've started to train staff
caseworkers in uh dealing specifically
with male
sexual violence survivors uh the
services are in their infancy right now
but it's something we we've definitely
identified to be a need
in the world's largest refugee camp the
humanitarian response and services
for male sexual violence survivors are
next to nothing
leaving most of the victims without any
counseling or help
chanvir choudhary al-jazeera cute